so today i'm canceling the nba um well
i'm not really canceling them or or
it isn't just me this is a democratic
cancellation we have canceled the nba
together
i i think for me i'm just sort of a
typical case
probably i never qualified as a die-hard
nba fan to begin with
but i did enjoy the sport and typically
became more invested during the playoffs
i loved watching the nba finals
especially and had missed probably
very few nba finals in the past decade
or so
i never had a home team but i rooted for
my favorite players
i had followed lebron james's career in
particular since his first stint with
the cleveland cavaliers
but i didn't watch a single minute of
this past nba season which just
concluded
lebron and the lakers won the trophy on
sunday i didn't realize the game was
even happening or that the lakers were
up in the series i didn't know anything
about it
i found out the next day due to the
viral footage of lakers fans rioting and
celebration because again
apparently celebrating a basketball
team's victory are immune to kovid just
like blm activists and
attendees of memorial services for
democrats all of them are immune
very very fascinating science so this
was the first nba season that i've ever
ignored
and i have to tell you i didn't miss it
being a sports fan is like being under
some sort of trance
you care immensely about this thing for
reasons you can't quite explain
but if the spell breaks and you stop
caring
you'll wonder why you ever did or why
you should start again
so for me the the spell broke because of
the nba's ceaseless political
propagandizing
too aggressive too wearying too
irritating just too much
this sort of thing may be tolerable up
to a certain line i'm not sure where
that line is exactly
but it has surely been crossed when a
league canonizes an accused rapist and
serial abuser like jacob blake
and its top star tries to foment more
division in chaos by telling wild tales
about racist cops
hunting black men and nearly all the
players and coaches decide to turn the
national anthem into a forum for
self-aggrandizing political stunts
that that's you crossed the line i can
deal with little a little bit of
politics from professional athletes
but if getting smacked in the face with
an ideological two by four is the price
of admission
i'd rather just go do something else
with my time
and i'm not alone according to nielsen
this was the lowest rated mba finals in
40 years
a mere 5.6 million viewers tuned in to
watch the game
that i didn't know was even being played
to put that in
put that in perspective perspective
double that number watched a regular
season sunday night football matchup on
the same night
game six of the finals last year had
three times the viewership back in the
michael jordan era in the 90s
the championship round would routinely
draw four five six times as many viewers
there's no mystery about why people are
tuning out now some in the sports world
have tried to rescue the nba
from the consequences of its own
politicizing claiming that viewership is
down
because of other things like kovid you
know for example yahoo sports
published an article yesterday arguing
that the ratings decline
suffered by other professional sports
leagues like the nfl and mlb
prove that politics can't be the driving
factor but
other professional sports leagues like
the nfl and mlb have also engaged in
political sermonizing to one degree or
another
if the nba is being hit especially hard
it's because they've been especially
loud while screeching from their soapbox
besides just ask the fans why they're
turning away they'll tell you
there was one poll done recently has
nearly 40 percent
watching fewer games because of
politicians politicization and that poll
separately counts uh the fans who've
switched off because of the nba's
dealings with china
so china hypocrisy and political
posturing which are two very
interconnected issues
together account for almost 60 percent
of fans these are not small numbers
this is not a small problem for the nba
now it's probably true
that covid isn't helping matters the
absence of fans does tend to make the
games less exciting
even without all the social justice
stuff but kovid the election the riots
all of the other unpleasant and
worrisome subjects dominating the news
are major reasons why so many americans
would like to turn to sports for an
escape and major reasons
why we have little interest in our
sports escapism being served to us with
a side of left-wing moralizing
it's like it's like you know going to
chuck e cheese as a child
only to be told that you can't jump in
the ball pit or go on the jungle gym
until you complete your multiplication
tables and finish a plate of brussels
sprouts
chuck e cheese exists precisely to be a
place
where multiplication tables and brussels
sprouts don't exist
you have defeated the purpose by
combining these two universes
now granted that may not be the best
analogy because vegetables and
mathematics are good for you even if you
don't like them
blm talking points on the other hand
promoted so relentlessly by the nba are
not good
or true or healthy or helpful in any way
it's just that when we turn on the news
or
we enter into a political debate with
someone we're prepared to encounter and
engage
with that kind of rhetoric they're part
of the bargain
they should not be need not be part of
the sports bargain
which makes our tolerance in that
setting much lower
we would rather sit and watch the game
enjoy the sport for its own sake
focus on a fun and frivolous and
pointless thing for a while
and that's it and if that's too much to
ask so be it we'll turn the tv off
and turn our energies elsewhere and you
know
it's probably for the best on second
thought
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated